i've had the opportunity to be next to
you i've been at turner now
15 plus years you've pulled a lot of
some of my best games when i played for
the pacers
and there's a lot of men and women who
have sat next to you
and you have treated everyone with the
utmost respect you
gifted the game of basketball with your
voice
thank you marv i know there's a lot of
emotions that are going through you i
know
ej and the inside guys are going to
interview you in a little bit but
what is going through your head right
now
as this is this is the end of an
unbelievable era
well first thanks very much for the nice
thoughts that you have just passed on
and
reggie with tonight's game winding down
i'm thinking well this is it my last
broadcast and all that's going through
my mind as i have been
so fortunate to be doing this nice photo
here for 55 years
doing what i love having a front row
seat for so many of the
iconic moments of sports history that's
marty glickman on my uh right
there i'm taking julius to the hole
right here nice
but doing it throughout the years with
people who are at the top of their game
brilliant at their craft and reggie it's
such a pleasure working with you you're
a hall of famer
as a player as a broadcaster and as a
person
and our gifted people on the truck
producer
tom heights and director andrew
greathouse and statistician brian taylor
uh production crew are fantastic camera
people
love to mention all the names but time
does not allow
everyone to turn to sports who do such a
great job starting with the
chairman of warner media news and sports
jeff
zucker who happens to be an nba fanatic
and the guys inside the nba ernie
charles kenny and shaq you are the best
in the business we'll be hearing from
you guys soon and ernie as i said to you
a couple of weeks back i wish
i were starting all over again it has
been
such a joy so for the last time
thanks so much for watching i'm marv
albert saying
thank you and good night